I have a medisthenic breast cancer that's to the bones when a January and February went off all my meds
Talked to my functional medical doctor as she ordered an estardial and it is
26 is this in range?
Would you consider this okay?
She thought it might be a bit high yet she wants it possibly to add
one the three C from pure encapsulation so one three C is a is a product like dim that will help
decrease that estrogens
Just started the astral clear and was so far as I'm
So there's nothing wrong with you really can't take too much dim. You know our aroma clear is good
Because got one three C and dim and another thing in it
But let's take a step back on this level of 26 of estardial so pulled up a
This is a Dutch test readout so
It your estardial levels really depend your estrogen and progesterone testosterone levels your horrible levels really dependent
how you're measuring them
So if the estardial was measured on a urine
Dutch test so a Dutch test is an acronym for a dried urine test
Something for hormones
Um, and it uses a proprietary type of
Measuring device that um is is that's what a Dutch test is now. There's multiple labs that have that type of equipment
This is through precision diet up diagnostics this readout right here. This is the Dutch test. I recommend
There's other doctors that will do a blood test for estrogens or they'll do a
A saliva test for estrogens to me. Those are not accurate. So here's the estardial so estardial is E2
right here
Now you see the normal of for estardial is
1.8 to 4.5 so
I this I cannot believe that an estardial of 26 was from a Dutch test in
It just does that does not make sense to me
So
This is your this is the reason why I love the Dutch test because it really gives a whole picture of all your
Your horrible metabolites. So metabolite is
This product in this this um molecule in your body breaks down to
molecule B breaks down the molecule C breaks down the molecule D and sometimes molecule B is the most active molecule and molecule C is is
A kind of a dangerous metabolite and if that's too high it can cause damage to the body
We're hoping that it breaks down the molecule D before it causes any damage until you measure these
What are called metabolites?
This is very important with formal metabolism
So you look up in this quarter up here and you have your
Progesterones so this person in this example
I just pulled this off the website so this is a dead patient here
This person has very low progesterone see how
Normal is the star to the star there in a low range here
There low progesterone low progesterone now progesterone will convert us into esterone
It will aromatize into esterone in aromatize into esterdiol
So aromatization we've talked about this a lot and you guys some women might be on an aromatase
Inhibitor aromatase is the name of an enzyme that is followed in
Fat cells of all of our fat cells in both males and females
So males and females have an enzyme called aromatase in the fat cells and it breaks down excess hormones
Into testosterone and estrogen and typically into bad estergins
quarter quote
So we don't want to
End up with excess hormones in our fat cells
Well, if you have excess hormones of any kind you will push them to your fat cells if you don't
If you don't get rid of them in the toilet and hormones are the number one things that are reabsorbed in the lower part of the colon
So males and females could have excess
Estergins and testosterone and progesterolds in their fat cells of guarantee you do
And then they can break down and break down into testosterone and bad estergins and that could cause issues
So that's called the aromatization because it uses the enzyme aromatase to break down those excess
Hormones that are stored in fat cells now it'll break down into the estergins. So these are the estergins here
And esterode is E1 and esterdiol is E2 and esterol is E3 and it breaks down through these different and through these different
genetic pathways these are cytokine P450 pathways
And it breaks down into 16 hydroxy esterode
Esterol and then it breaks down into 4 hydroxy esterode and this is the one that can really cause damage to cells and can cause
Cancer so any of these any of these estergins in excess any of these estergins in excess all of these right here
any of these in excess can attach to
Estrogen beta receptors on the cell membranes of cancer cells
If it does that and the estrogen beta receptor is an apoptotic receptor so it blocks apoptosis so it blocks the
death of that cell
So that's the whole idea with estrogen positive and her two positive cancers
And progesterone positive cancers too. It's estergins. Any of these estergins if they're high
If this one is high, it could be a cause of cancer. Okay, any of these are high. They can attach to the
Estrogen beta receptors and then
Be an issue with blockade apoptosis. So the idea of
taking an
Aromatase inhibitor is to get rid of these estergins
So you
Those won't attach to the estrogen beta receptors and block apoptosis. That's the whole idea
The same thing the whole idea of taking, you know, esteroclear and so poroside and
I3C and
DIM are to do the same things to get rid of the bad estergins so that
These excess estergins and to help bring balance to your body
That's that's the whole idea of taking them
So an ester dial of 26 had to be a measured
It and I believe not on a Dutch test but on a blood test and really I think you should get a Dutch test
A Dutch test is a good test and you can just order it and you do it at home
But for urine test send it in takes about 10 days
To get it back and it gives you nice results. This is this person if this person this example
Of here had cancer and be concerned especially at any hormone driven cancer. They have high esterols high ester dials
You want these things
Way down here you want this little arrow here way down here this way down here
This way down here this this is really bad and I think they use this as an example because this could be a cancer causing
Result here. This should not be read. It should be greed way down here. You want these way down here
As many of them as possible some of these
Methylated ones can be high. This is why
COMT defects with with breast cancer patients can be a problem because it could increase the two methoxy
esterols and
This would be a perfect example. So this example if this is a true example unless they just
Changed the numbers on here, but if this is a true example. This is quite possibly a person with a lot of
Comp defects COMT defects
Okay
So I would suggest there's another role with taking
more of the estrogen-lowering products, but I would suggest you get a more proper test done